than
morning
yeah I liked it ni day
pleas
morning everybody the time being 10:15
we'll get uh going here on the executive
session so first I will open the
executive session on HB 1254 and
recognize representative spillsbury
thank you Mr chairman um I move itl on
hb1
1254 do I have a
second second by
Jordan would you like to speak to your
motion yes uh thank you Mr chairman
um I think we all recognize that a very
strong case was made um by a variety of
proponents at the
hearing or some kind of an accommodation
that allows them to raise funds that can
be directed
towards um local Services particularly
Public Safety police fire
Etc um I'm recalling
particularly the case being made
regarding Conway and Portsmith two very
different municipalities and
situations so
so the concern is
real something probably should be done
the question though is whether this bill
does it in a way that uh on balance
makes
sense this is an isolated fee it creates
a new fee in the law there's no
precedent
for it um delegates to the localities to
decide whether to have a fee not have a
fee have it at $2 or have it up to
$2 uh there is as representative ol had
suggested a checkerboard effect that may
occur um I also thought it was very
interesting particularly in the
discussion that
followed
that while the
pressure of visitors to the Mount
Washington Valley and the Conway area is
largely linked to
lodging there are a host of other kinds
of pressures that arise retail
centers Portsmith is probably more of a
restaurant pressure than a lodging
pressure towns that are along the
Vermont main or Massachusetts border
tend to attract a lot of uh activity
coming uh into the state in my town on a
given day half the plates are Vermont
license plates Lebanon was uh described
by representative Aly and that's not
necessarily a vacation or lodging
situation
so I think we realize that while the
Conway
situation is begging for a solution the
issue represents itself in different
ways in different communities and a more
comprehensive solution is what we need
and so I did
suggest and I'd be happy to be part of
uh trying to do something with with this
that we may want to look at the meals
and rooms tax we've had suggestions of
reducing the rate maybe and and I'm not
pushing this yet it's just a suggestion
maybe we look at the idea of reducing
the rate but then having a a local uh
sear charge so I just think that it's
it's a serious
issue um we shouldn't uh vote itl with
the intention of burying it but we
should we should not move this bill
forward and we should revisit
it thank
you any other discussion representative
Aly thank
you um we've been working on this bill
for quite a while it gets obscured by
the uh pressure from Portsmith and the
pressure now from on the uh Lakes
Region and
parts of of the North Country uh for uh
help with the huge increase they get
during the day uh during during certain
weeks and and
Seasons uh for uh from tourists
on and then there's a lot of others of
us that get the pressure
because we
uh our retail centers and job centers
for our regions and the people who live
outside of the urban Hub I call them for
uh
and are benefiting in their property
taxes because most of the services that
they use are in the urban Hub and the
urban Hub frequently most the time I
think H also has nonprofit services that
are also used uh for the entire region
and so the The Hub loses property tax
from having the nonprofits there and it
loses uh tax um on it it increases its
services particularly in public safety
meas measures I think that this is the
one change we've made since uh previous
years that's significant is that um I
was struggling with the people who do do
with do tourism to get them to
understand there are a lot of other
places that have this problem and the
committee has recognized that problem
um but
um uh the idea of bringing it forward
for the Public Services the public
safety uh issues not just of of fire of
um enforcement of of
uh uh planning regulations of uh the
number of people who come in and behave
badly uh on
either stealing or or running into each
other's
cars um and creating huge traffic
jams uh and
um but also um the health emergencies
that come up when those people are there
during the day and for the tourism areas
during the night um that uh run into
medical problems and have to uh have
help from our
EMTs
um
so this is something that seemed to us a
simple and it's not a by any means a
complete solution but uh the towns that
we have consulted towns and cities that
we have consulted about this uh really
believe that this will help us to try to
keep our property taxes down Lebanon has
the highest property taxes north of
Claremont uh in in our region in our uh
in the Northwest
country and I think they rival a lot of
the ones in SE
Coast
um and it means that that the urban core
is also
losing uh its lower lower income and
middle income people we've lost a huge
number of our middle inome people we
have a lot of subsidized housing that's
one of our
services and we're continuing to do it
but um the middle income people have
found that in order to be able to
survive they have to move out to the
bedroom
communities
and on we didn't want to impose
something that would
hit our neighbors our neighboring
communities which is what we'd do if we
started trying to put some kind of a fee
or increase a tax on rooms and
meals um which is mostly
meals and
uh so
um I think that this is a
reasonable partial solution to the
problem and I'm going to be going up on
the
floor probably with the
sponsor uh to defend it uh next week if
it's in the calendar next week
um so that's thank
you
um represent
Edwards uh thank you Mr chair I a bill
very much like this presented itself to
ways and means when when I was a a
member of this committee uh the term
before last and uh I agree with uh
everything the the the the my colleague
from lean has said and I agree with the
the initial representative that this is
a real issue it's been a real issue for
several years I I I think I think to the
question of what's the best way to
address it uh it it it seems to me that
we used to have a
philosophy that uh we should keep our
tax structure simple and uh and so uh
since government does one of two things
basically we tax and we spend what what
I think I would rather see as a
strategic approach is is rather than
messing with the tax code to complicate
it and delegate it uh I think I'd rather
acknowledge that there's a problem on
the on this and handle it on the
spending side I it would be great I
think if there were some sort of a
public safety Grant like located
somewhere like in the tourism area or or
somewhere where a very simple Grant
application could be submitted to seek
reimbursement for the incremental costs
accumulated for The Unique needs of that
Community because uh that way um the
complexity of the range of towns and
their needs could be incorporated better
and done in a more flexible way where
the state on the spending side every two
years we take a look at spending and
that's very flexible once something gets
into the tax code I think most of us
know it it's inflexible and is probably
not going to adapt uh as Society adapts
so so I I I I I I agree with the the
motion um and uh and I hope that we
don't drop the ball for another two
terms on this
issue thank you representative
shamberg oh Southworth thank you um for
the chair we haven't had this situation
I don't think yet in this committee but
I just wanted to clarify if we split
evenly which would be 1010 it would go
OTP but there'd be thorough descriptions
of each
side that is correct if it split 1010
it'll go to the floor as OTP pardon me I
think and then also I think it would go
uh without
recommendation motion would be OTP yes
that's correct um and the other point
I'd make and I'm not sure I heard it
already is this is enabling
legislation um which really does give
choice to a lot of communities about
what they want to
do thank you uh representative
uh shamberg shamberg yeah thank you Mr
chairman
uh I'm a member of the wiet select board
I'm also the chairman of the select
board
and who better knows what their
community
needs than the local
government that is operating a a a
town
uh we don't have the uh draw that a
Conway does or a Lebanon or Peterboro or
along the coast
Portsmouth but they come here and
they've presented this as a way to
resolve what they know is a problem and
it looks like we're wanting central
government to dictate or say we know
better
and as a local elected official in
wilmet and
Sutton I find that this is a very
reasonable bill to help solve the
problem and going to representative
edwards's uh uh statements uh you speak
very well on it but it sounds like we
want to
make the decision here when we have a
piece of legislation that would solve
taking central government out of it and
letting our locals decide enabling
legislation as representative
Southworth thank you for
that thank you representative elme did
you have oh okay representative
uh um
elberger thank you Mr chairman uh I want
to re reiterate uh representative
southworth's comment that this is not an
imposition of a tax this is enabling
legislation to allow local control so
that communities that know what they
need can deal with it the best way they
can uh I have no idea how the potential
of lowering the rooms and meals tax
would help in this regard at all as
representative spillsbury mentioned
uh we have
already been adding to our budget in in
light of uh representative Edwards
comments about grants to Regions we have
already increased our budget this year
due to the funding for the efas and
presumably we're going to be getting a
request from the governor to spend
almost a million dollars to send some of
our national guards people to Texas to
the border
and this is a way for the state to not
have to deal with any additional
funding but leave it to the localities
to make up their own minds about what
they need it makes to me no sense to say
to localities no we know better than you
so I am uh opposed to representative
spilsbury's motion and will be hopefully
voting to pass it now pass this
bill representative Bolton thank you Mr
chair um i' I'd like to affirm and um I
guess um agree with representative
shamberg um I am also uh on the Plymouth
select board I'm I'm the vice chair
currently and uh Plymouth is a community
that has over 53% of its properties uh
nonprofit are owned by nonprofits and we
have to deal with um basically
maintaining the safety and and health of
those um areas uh with our limited
budget uh within the Plymouth residence
and so you know greater than half of our
town is maintained by um people that are
are under exorbitant taxes and the
university that is in the town also
provides um some help but it also
provides some challenges you know we
have uh pirate parties and and um
different um celebrations that the
University students undergo and that
increases the load on our our police
force we've had to uh
engage um other you know police as well
and pay for their ability to maintain
the peace um and so when we're offered
or perhaps uh able to like take
advantage of something that we might be
able to charge um you know $2 or a fee
for a state and in hotels in our
community um it seems like a unique
opportunity and something that we
actually need um very desperately
otherwise we just rely on increasing
property taxes so um I would also oppose
the
itl okay uh representative
duet thank you Mr
chairman and I think my colleagues have
made the point that I'm going to make
right now local control is most
important but in that I I don't
presently serve or have served in my
local government but I know that my
local government at least in Salem takes
a very hard look before they make
approvals for hotels ins lodging
establishments okay there's City
Planning town planning impact fees etc
etc etc so there was an argument made
for these establishments to go into
these
communities
why is it
now an issue for us to address where the
lack of appropriate planning becomes an
issue okay I I think we we can't go to
the we for each each problem we have a
huge water problem in the state right
now do we assess or allow for
assessments for certain Fe I mean this
incrementally should be done at the
local level it should be handled at the
local level and if there's another means
I I just don't agree with this
vehicle at all thank you representative
roachford thank you Mr chairman and I
think that I've made my position clear
uh in that I come from a and I rep I'm
here to represent a district and that's
I'm here to to speak for my constituents
and and I come from a town a population
about 5,800 and any given day it swells
to
25,000 um Littleton New Hampshire 5,800
people has a full-time 24hour 7day a
week fire department we recently added a
full-time 24hour 7-Day a week Ambulance
Service um we're going to be talking
about uh the need come soon to add an
additional $300,000 ambulance to our uh
our our Emergency
Services
the the difference is we don't have a
lot of hotel rooms in the in the town of
Litteton we don't have a lot of lodging
facilities we don't have a lot of Border
houses what we have is shopping centers
we have big boxes we have restaurants we
have a we have breweries we have things
that want people want to come and see
and and and do and take part in but as a
result it puts strain on our Emergency
Services like everyone has said
here I'm I'm going to I'm going to
support the itl motion and again to to
reiterate my
colleague not because it is something
that I oppose the idea of but I don't
think this bill goes far enough I don't
think a fee on the lodging would
actually adequately address the needs of
my community um you know I look at a fee
on housing in rooms and in motels and we
we don't have a ton of those but we have
a lot of restaurants and we pay a
significant amount of rooms and meals
tax per capita for our area and there
are areas that don't have any
restaurants or or facilities at all um
that are benefiting from that so I I
agree with the concept wholeheartedly
agree with the concept I'm 100% on board
with it uh but I think that this
mechanism is not the the right approach
for my constituents and uh if if if we
can itl this this year bring it back
next year and and do something that
would be a little more comprehensive I
and address the needs more adequately of
my community I'd be happy to support
that before I call the next person um I
represent Salem Salem would fit into
roughly what you just said our
population in Salem swells from
something like 30,000 to 100,000 on any
particular day and we don't have many
hotels to collect that from so a more
comprehensive solution would would make
sense uh representative elberger thank
you Mr chairman uh representative ducet
said something about leaving this to the
localities that's exactly what this bill
is trying to do say to the localities
make your decision about it the argument
that because we don't have a perfect
all-encompassing solution to an issue to
me doesn't mean let's wait until we do
because it may take us 20 years to get a
perfect solution if we can start by
taking a step in this regard we may be
able to also say at some point hopefully
not too long in the future the
communities that don't have restaurants
can also look at adding a fee for some
other
services we don't need to have a first
bill be the complete solution it can be
the first step to a complete
solution you
spillsbury yes thank you Mr chairman you
know I I think the comments around the
table have been
constructive and the observations about
what factually is going on in a variety
of communities are not anything I would
argue with I think representative rord
put it very
well I think the problem here is number
one this is a fragment of larger problem
and number two without looking at the
larger problem and the implications for
other communities that have pressures
caused by different
factors we don't know whether this is an
appropriate
mechanism so we've got communities where
it's the overnight lodging crowd we've
got communities where it's the
restaurant crowd we got communities
where maybe it's a casino got
communities where it's retail we have
communities that are employment centers
and Border communities that may be a
blend of several of those so I just
think it would be unwise to move this
bill without thinking more
comprehensively about what would work
for that variety of
communities representative
leapley thank you Mr
chair I agree that the conversation has
been very productive I think part of
what we're all talking about is that we
need a broad and diverse source of
Taxation and I think it's clear that if
we had a comprehensive bill it wouldn't
pass because it would be a list of new
taxes so I feel like we have to do
something in New Hampshire that where we
act like a community where we act like
as communities we have something in
common and if we're going to do taxation
at the state level which it sounds like
people here some people here are saying
it has to be done by the state we don't
want it done
locally we have to have a mechanism to
share that with the localities in a way
that makes sense we have yet to find
that solution and it seems like
ideologically many people are opposed to
taxation period and what we've done as a
body is cut all of any kind of diverse
source of taxation so we keep putting it
back on the property taxpayers we've we
cut the indd tax so we keep taking out
sources of Taxation nobody wants to pass
new taxes and so we're not replacing
those and so again it just comes back to
property taxes so I feel like this is a
modest proposal
$2 that is targeted to hit folks who
aren't currently paying taxes in New
Hampshire right this is people who are
staying in hotels so people who are
costing the state something and who
aren't necessarily paying in or maybe
not perfectly so we have a room in meals
tax that's you know collecting some at
the
restaurant this would collect a little
bit more in the hotels if we want to
talk about a sales tax then you're
talking about retail right people are
saying well we have retail spaces and
this isn't capturing it
so I think a series of very modest very
targeted proposals make sense in this
case it's very modest and it's targeted
to the people who need to kick in a
little bit because they're enjoying our
our state maybe on the weekend or for a
week at a time I think it's fair to ask
them to kick in and it seems fair to me
to ask the localities who know best to
decide if this is for them or not thank
you
thank
you do we have any other uh yes repres
Aly uh just um a couple of things um
this
isn't just about tourism we have a lot
of of towns that or cities Urban cores
that have this problem around the
state and um it is not always was a
problem that our
ancestors uh created for us in Lebanon
um our mayor did set up a contract with
the hospital when it moved over from
Hanover and brought a huge amount of
extra work with it um and sprawl
uh but um and we went through a fouryear
uh
fight when we tried to uh on get them to
pay a pilt that meant something the the
mayor had given it to them in perpetuity
for two $2
million uh and we ran out of the money
in 11 years so um but um and they also
made some other mistakes that we have
been paying for for 50 years now uh but
on Plymouth did not ask to have a State
University and the State University
doesn't
pay and we didn't ask to have the
services that we still have that are
based in Lebanon that belong to the
state
government and um a lot of of places
that our Urban cores do have uh service
I think Littleton has a fair number of
of these Services they've been taking
them out of Lebanon because our rents
are so high um they're higher than
anybody else's now
um
and and so this this isn't just about
tourism this is about the imbalance when
you depend depending only on a almost
entirely in your tax system on a local
property
tax which only takes from the people
that live inside the boundaries of the
town and I hear a lot of interest in
trying to figure out other ways to do
this um one of the things that's been
motivating us with this one is that it
doesn't take from our
neighbors because we think that we have
more neighbor Neighbors in the
legislature than we do
cores so that we wouldn't be able to get
those
through
um I think others have talked about the
um problems
of of a um of trying to get everybody
into something it is not a tax it is a
fee it is a set amount which is $2 or
under for a hotel room which is little
enough that very few visitors would pay
any attention to it
whatsoever
um but
um yeah and I did want to just say about
the
amendment that um what it does is to
restrict the rooms and meals definition
of hotel to just on places that are
easier for the towns
to um to um talk with and um uh get by
in from uh ins motels lodging rooms
lodging homes rooming houses boarding
houses and
hostels there um and then it defines
occupant um the nor the way that rooms
and meals does but it it says that um
should we be talking about the amendment
now the initial motion is still on the
floor well you told me I could talk
about the amendment so I I I did I did
tell her she could talk about the
amendment um and uh I I I would just but
I would just um also say that I think
the arguments have been pretty well laid
out I think we know where this is going
right um
so if you want to make one last
statement on it uh well just say that
um it can't if uh that it keeps FL flop
houses from having to pay uh pay this
fee the occupants of flop houses by the
the occupant average daily price of the
occupancy not exceeding
$40 um and it um specifies that only up
to 30 days would at one visit would
would be paid okay thank you um unless
somebody has something new to add to
this discussion I think we're to the
point where we should I'm going to ask
the clerk to call the
role the motion is to itl
1254 represent janigan chairman
janigan yes are we dealing with the
amendment at all no because the motion
is it representative janigian yes
representive Edwards yes represent oler
yes represent ducet yes represent
spillsbury yes represent PL votes yes
representative lels yes represent
representative
disimone yes yes representative ORS yes
representative roord yes representative
Aly no representative Ames no
representative Southworth no
representative am Maloy no
Representative shamberg no
Representative fellos no representative
Bolton no Representative elberger no
Representative leapley no representative
Smith no the vote is
the vote being 1010 this will not go on
consent so it's without
recommendation well there the um
there'll be there will be a report for
itel and a report against it so majority
report will be by um representative
spillsbury because that was the motion
okay and the Minority Report will be by
represent
Aly okay Mr chair I'm gonna close the
exact
session okay since it's
1010 um I I think the itl motion
technically has failed and this is meant
to default to an
OTP if it's defaulting to an TP should
we separately consider the amendment so
because I I'm a little confused here
should should should it say on the house
calendar uh otpa or should it just say
OTP how how procedurally how does that
work my we may have to check with the
clerk um my understanding it's
otpa uh and we don't address the
amendment no okay no it's not2 it can't
be without a vote you can't be with an a
until you vote I think the amendment
would be introduced on the floor
no let's chair yes
M am representative Ames had his hand up
first yeah I I believe the correct
procedure is as representative Edward
stated that that we we started out with
a motion to itl that failed on a 10 to
10 vote
next up is a motion which hasn't been
made to U ought to pass an OTP motion uh
which will be followed I understand by a
motion to
amend and um we'll we have to work
through
that probably to another 10 to 10 result
and now we're position for the reports
that speak to the second part that we
couldn't that makes that makes sense uh
is that what you going to say yeah
represent D okay all right um we will
proceed under that
uh so the itl U has failed because
there's no uh because it was a TI vote
um representative Aly I think we can
make this quick I move move what I move
on ought to pass with Amendment no to
pass ought to pass first right do I have
a
second um repres elberger on
1254 um would you like to to speak to
your motion very quickly yeah I I would
just like to um say that on I would like
to move uh the UT to pass with amend the
amendment okay the amendment being being
um
uh 2024
d681 yes that's
right so um does the amendment need to
be seconded I believe it does second by
representative Southworth on the
amendment all right we'll give you a
chance to catch up this is I'm always
confused when we do this because I was
taught it's ought to pass and then you
do the Amendments separately so uh but
you don't do you don't vote on the ought
to pass first you vote on ought to pass
with the amendment usually yeah always
you have to vote on we have to vote on
the amendment first yeah okay so the
motion is uh to uh the amendment
yeah the motion is ought to pass on the
amendment
itself yeah uh which o6
81h
yes okay so the clerk will call the role
on the
amendment um is I I'm assuming there's
no discussion is there any discussion on
the
amendment okay seeing none the clerk
will call the role
is-
0681 all right uh the amendment uh 2024
0681 H rep uh chairman Jen inan
no
uh representative Edwards no represent
oler no representat no Representative
spillsbury no representative PL votes no
Representative lels no representative
ORS no Representative rord no represent
Aly yes oh excuse me I missed represent
thisone
first thank you for remembering me I
vote no
okay okay representative Aly voted yes
yes representative Ames yes
representative Southworth yes
representative Malloy yes representative
shamberg yes representative fellows yes
represent Bolton yes represent elberger
yes representative leapley yes represent
Smith yes predictably 1010 the mo the uh
Amendment
fails so now now we are on
OTP so now we're it's OTP on the
original
bill um
which let's have the attention up here
please does do you have does someone
have a
question okay the motion the motion is
now OTP of the original bill which
I know there were several questions and
that's why representative Aly had
brought an amendment so it may change
the
complexity uh on this uh do I have any
discussion on the OTP on the bill
itself and I'd just like to say that
I've seen on some of these without
recommendations that it
says on the and there's an ought to pass
with amendment that is explained only
inside of the
blurb of the report from the a to pass
person so I guess that's what we have to
do well the motion still is onp only the
motion would
BEP
TP OTP only correct and um then in the
blur one refers to the
amendment right in the blurb you can
refer to the amendment representative
Edwards did you I I was just going to
say this is really a good uh set of
questions for the clerk uh because it
seems like the the house calendar at
this point should say OTP and should
have the two reports in it uh and
because the amendment did not pass uh I
don't even know that it uh should be
referred to in either report uh it it it
does make itself available to be uh
introduced on the floor um but but I
think just as a matter of clarification
the chair may want to talk to the clerk
to find out what the rules of including
references to the amendment are in the
report itself for the house calendar I
because I don't know I just it just
feels to me like a a a gray area
there that yeah on the face of it that
makes sense thank you representative
Edwards we will check with the clerk
before putting doesn't seem to be what
happens well before we before you write
up the blurb or before we submit the
blurb we'll talk to the clerk to find
out um situation on that representative
Southworth uh thank you I know some of
its terminology so the buold will say
without
recommendation and then the first blurb
even though they're not calling them
blurbs anymore will be for passage or
support of the bill and that certainly
can mention the amendment um and then
the second one will be opposed to the
bill I I mean the my guess is that the
otp's uh well I don't know we have to
see what the OTP does because I don't
know if the same support is going to
ensue or not because there was a reason
that representa Aly brought an amendment
that was concerned with the bill itself
um so I'm not sure how that vote's going
to go before when it says has said
without recommendation certainly um the
um supportive section can reference an
amendment that made the bill better I
mean I have seen that before because why
would you do it differently if it's 101
yeah no I I I understand your point I
don't want to argue it here because we
don't know we'll check CL have the final
say uh representative PL I would imagine
the people uh put putting forth the OTP
could have a floor Amendment which
exists which is the same Amendment but
introduced as a floor Amendment yeah
they definitely could representa Aly
could if she wants introduce it as a
floor
amendment I could but then people
wouldn't read
it okay any uh any discussion on the
bill itself because that's all we're
looking at now representative ducet Mr
chair I just contacted the uh the clerk
he's going to take a run over here and
and help us straighten out this black
Meer so perfect if you want to hold so
maybe
we all right we will uh oh he might be
here
no timing was right what we need is
someone education because they always do
this can I re I don't think you close
but we could go on can
I okay all right I'm going to uh recess
HB 1254 temporarily while we wait for
the clerk to arrive um and this could be
him
perfect perfect timing I'm not going to
recess hp1
1254 okay so the question at hand so we
the motion was itl on HB 1254 the vote
was 1010 so the itl failed uh we then
went to uh
OTP and um an amendment was introduced
the amendment then failed 1010 so now we
are back to OT P just the bill which we
have not voted on that's where we are at
right now and then we had some questions
about um how this should appear let's
say the vote now well actually we I
don't maybe we should vote on the OTP
and then we can ask you
but good morning good morning uh you're
going to want to vote on the OTP if the
OTP fails
then you can submit without
recommendation and you can have either
uh statement in support of ought to pass
ought to pass with Amendment two ought
to pass with amendments itl
whatever okay and then um Can the
amendment be referred to in the in the
um blurb or not in the report uh you can
you can refer to an amendment that would
do something but you you don't we don't
list uh numbers specifically in
committee reports okay so just the idea
of what the amendment would do MH okay
Mr chairman yes
um yes uh who's representative
spillsbury
so I understand an amendment can then be
brought up on the floor but it would not
be characterized as a committee
Amendment it would have to be brought as
a floor Amendment no it can be
transmitted as uh it's B basically half
the committee supports an amendment and
that the the positive motion goes first
on the floor when it's without
recommendation represent PL I have a
clerk question I I went through clerk
School beginning of this term I recall
yes uh but and what I learned there is
when a case like this I I wrote ought to
pass but then adoption of amendment
number on the same line and so the
chairman asked for uh ought to pass for
uh move in second but that doesn't apply
I the the ought to pass for Amendment as
what I put down was represents Aly and
Southworth the amendment failed so then
I went to a to pass with Aly and
elberger which was the uh which who who
who going to make the initial motion to
a to pass is that correct the the you
can only accept an an amendment on a
positive motion yes so the person who
moves the ought to pass and seconds the
ought to pass is the same whether or not
the amendment is adopted or
not okay we can we can kits on that
later if you need to I don't want to I
don't want to hold up time all right
fine uh if they were same people it
wouldn't bother me but there's two
different sets of people on one
line okay all right we'll we clarify
that representative fellows yes I I just
was wondering the amendment does it have
to go in the pocket or can it be printed
in the coun no if if um with respect uh
there have been many uh committee
amendments that have been sent over
without recommendation and they are all
in the calendar uh that being said if a
floor amendment is drafted that can that
would come later and could be in SE
Pockets so this floor Amendment 1010 can
go in the it's not it's not a floor
Amendment it's it's it's an amendment
being offered here yeah so okay
representative Amy one more question on
the
floor
on I get up and move what to pass and
offer amendments such and such and I
then can go forward immediately to so I
if you if you've uh noticed on the floor
when we've when we've had a without
recommendation and the report is uh
statement in support of ought to pass
with Amendment uh I write down on the
sheet for the speaker representative
alme moves out to pass and offers
Amendment such and such so that's how
that works thank you thank you that's
great any other questions for the clerk
I hope
not thank you very much for coming right
over we appreciate
it okay so now we are back to ought to
pass the bill with no Amendment any
discussion on the bill ought to pass
with no
Amendment okay the clerk will call the
RO motion is ought to pass uh represent
a chairman janigian no uh representative
Edwards no Representative oler no
representative DEET no Representative
spillsbury no representative PL fots no
uh Representative lels no represent of
is D Simone no represent ORS
no represent of rord no represent Aly
yes represent of Ames yes represent uh
Southworth yes represent Malloy yes
representative shamberg yes
representative fellows yes
representative Bolton yes representative
elberger yes representative uh leapley
yes represent Smith yes vote predictably
is 1010 and it fails okay OTP
fails so I have now without
recommendation and I have majority
report author representative Aly
Minority Report author spillsbury
representa spillsbury
makes sense okay
all
right so thank you this is confusing
learn something and and it's great that
uh representative Aly can have her
Amendment printed into the calendar
because I never would have guessed
that yeah yes I wouldn't have thought
that either this was a um a good
learning experience for me too all right
I will close the exec session on
12:54
okay now let's see how we do on the next
one I'm going to open the exec session
on HB 1203 relative to prohibiting the
charging of rent to
Charities Mr chair sure I vote ought to
pass with an
amendment I move to ought to pass in an
amendment I would to introduce well
right now the motion's to pass do I have
I'll second that motion Mr chair second
by represent
shamberg bill number is 123
1203 okay date
2 uh to
pass Mr chair yes can can I excuse
myself I was supposed to introduce a
bill
um I'll come back as soon as I can it
may already be too late okay all right
this is a good this is good okay and Mr
chair I I would move forward would you
like to speak to your
motion um I would like to speak to the
amendment you'd like to introduce an
amendment yes introduce an amendment
okay soon as I find it it's on it's in
front of
everybody yeah okay amendment is number
uh six
82h and what the amendment does is
essentially the same bill but Mr chair
can I second that OT oh yes yes do I
have a second yes representative
shamberg thank
you we're still recovering from the last
one to
H uh okay would you like to speak yes
the amendment first all it does is it's
this bill is the same but it adds in
lines 25 and 26 no char itable
organization shall receive less than 35%
of the gross revenue from many games of
chance minus any prizes paid and that
fixes the bill that inadvertently
dropped the
35% uh so it puts it back into law if we
pass it right thank you and the bill
itself with that passage uh is
essentially eliminating the rents
charged to Charities and that's all it
does right okay anything else seeing
none well
one
yes hiding there so um when we had a
hearing uh before I had to go seat uh
seat myself out in in that area I spoke
with um our you know the person that you
know looks at conflicts uh over in the
house and um what I need to do is just
State the fact that I'm an executive
director of a charity not a charity well
it's um a nonprofit that receives uh
terrible gambling uh monies okay and uh
after um speaking with the U the person
that in the house we we determined that
I just have to announce the fact that
our charity receives money and um okay
but doesn't exclude me from you can
still vote yep okay thank you
representative
ducet I just have a quick question I
don't know if it's appropriate or not to
ask director uh McIntyre reading the
added line here in
2526 this would be specific to games of
chance would not be inclusive of
anything else Vis HHR as far as this 35%
okay I know what the legislative intent
is I just want to make sure there's no
thank you okay okay
yeah represent
elme very briefly to representative
Bolton would you me Rich
Lambert yes record thanks thank you
okay all right um seeing no more
discussion the clerk will call the role
on the amendment first yes uh yes repres
chairman janigan yes representative
Edwards has not stepped out but I'll
call on him later rep represent ol huh
if he come no he's you can't okay so
I'll put him no vote no vote
okay representative erery yes
representative jet yes representative
spillsbury yes representative PL votes
yes representative lels yes represent or
uh representative de Simone
yes the problem I had to write your name
in the bottom because they uh H they
should have left the blank they
didn't huh she forgives you I'm
okay why I'm having struggling a little
bit uh representa ORS
oh oh he stepped out stepped down okay
represent Ro
yes represent Aly yes represent Ames yes
represent Southworth yes represent
Malloy yes representative shanberg yes
representative
fellows she Ste out too she's out too Bo
what's the popular bill
here represent Bolton yes represent
elberger
yes representative leapley yes
representative Smith yes the vote is 16
Z and of three not voting oh wait a
second
17 yeah
17 12 13 14 15 16 17 to zero not three
not
voting is there any objection to putting
this on consent well wait a second I got
to go the motion oh yeah okay okay so
the vote was
1703 now I move ought to pass with
Amendment
right and I assume representative uh
shanberg second I
second
okay we we've already asked the question
um I don't think you can
vote you won't be able to vote on
this you look
upset okay I'm ready uh the clerk will
call the role okay this is ought to pass
a with Amendment uh ought to PA with HBU
1203 chairman
janigian yes representative ol uh
representative Edwards is he still back
in no
no represent erery yes represent DEC yes
represent spillsbury yes represent PL
votes yes representative lels yes
represent or Ro can't vote I
correct representative
roord
yes representative Aly yes
representative Ames yes represent
Southworth yes represent Malloy yes
represent shamberg yes uh and again Mr
representative D Simone yes uh
representative fellows is she back in it
doesn't matter she was out okay
representative Bolton
yes representative
uh representative elberger yes
representative leapley yes
representative Smith yes vote is
1703 not
voting now is there any objection to
consent
seeing none we'll put that on the
consent and I'll close the executive
session on HB
123 okay I'll now open the exec session
on HB
and Rec uh recognize representative
leapley for a
motion representative leapley
recognizing you for a motion on HB 1255
oh 55 yeah excuse me I'm sorry um yes
I'd like to move
itl do I have a second on that second by
representative
ducet would you like to speak to your
motion yes I would this issue is being
addressed in a Senate bill so we don't
need to take it up here thank you any
other discussion representative elme
your microphone's on but oh
okay all right seeing none I'll ask the
clerk to call the
role what is the motion please the the
motion is itl on HB
1255 okay all set
y okay uh chairman janigian yes rep uh
representative Edwards is he back no no
represent
erery uh yes represent duet yes
represent spillsbury yes representative
PL votes yes representative lels yes
represent representative
pone yes you didn't call me last you
took me off guard well that's where I'm
supposed to take it but I skip over yeah
so so uh representative ORS yes
representative rord yes representa Alman
yes represent Ames yes represent
Southworth yes represent Malloy yes
representative shamberg yes represent
fellows yes represent Bolton yes
represent
elberger yes represent leapley yes
representa Smith yes okay 1901 not
voting okay the vote being 190 um any
objection to
consent seeing none we'll put this on
the consent
calendar okay uh does an itl need a
report yes okay and who's doing it uh
representative
leapley I will close the exact session
on HB
1255 next up is uh I will open the exact
session on HB
1389 and I'll recognize representative
shamberg for motion thank you Mr
chairman Mr chairman I'd like to
recommend itl
1389 do I have a second representative
du set
seconds would you like to speak to your
motion I just would like to say that
this bill has potentially unidentified
ramifications which
could have or lead to unintended
consequences succinct but true
in my opinion uh representative elme
yeah I think that we ought to add
something about um the
lottery and the committee are are going
to consider whether any more legislation
is
necessary uh anything else
okay he asked me seeing none the clerk
will call the role of on um HB 1389 and
the motion is to itl rep chairman
janigian yes representative Edwards is
back no no okay at the representative
erery yes representative duet yes
representative spillsbury yes
representative plos yes representative
lels yes representative D Mo yes
representative ORS yes representative
rord yes representative Aly yes
representative
Ames yes representative Southworth yes
representative Malloy yes representative
shanberg yes representative fellows yes
representative Bolton yes represent
elberger yes representative leapley yes
representative Smith yes the vote is
1901 not
voting the vote being 190 any objections
to consent seeing none this will also go
on
consent and uh represent shabber is
writing the report yes
yes I need to take a two-minute Break um
I'll be right
back
this form isn't right for I
pass you should have the right
it's
um looks like most most are
back we're going to skip uh hb1 1525
right now there's a um update to an
amendment that we're waiting for so
we'll move on to HB 1549 I'll open the
exec session on hb1
1549 relative to buying amount
deductions collected during the
operation of games of chance and I'll
recognize representative ducet
for a
motion
1549 forgive me yes I thank you Mr chair
I move out to pass on hb1
1549 do I have a
second second Mr chairman representative
shamberg seconds it and would you like
to speak to your motion real briefly as
we discussed a couple times does not
change uh the percentage of Charity gets
it puts a cap on those larger dollar ter
tournaments if they were in fact to
happen thank you any
discussion okay seeing none I'll ask the
clerk to take the
role ought to pass at 1549 chairman
janigian yes uh it representative
Edwards is not yet back correct correct
uh representative
erery yes representative
duet yes yes representative spillsbury
yes representative PL votes yes
representative lels yes representative D
Simone yes representative ores yes
representative Ros yes representative
Aly yes representative Ames yes
represent Southworth yes represent
Malloy yes represent shanberg yes
represent fellos yes representative
Bolton yes represent elberger yes
representative leapley yes
uh representative Smith yes okay vote is
1901 not voting on
1549 the vote being 190 any objection to
consent seeing none we'll put on the
consent and I will close the exec
session on hb1
I'll let the clerk catch up here which
one we
next uh
116 next
we'll exact
hp16 I'll open the exec session on
hp16 this one eliminates the fee to file
as C yes
are you skipping over uh cic
R15 yes we I'm skipping we'll we'll come
back to ccr5 and
hb152
um and
uh I'll repres I'll recognize
representative PL to make a motion on
hp16 Mr chair I I move
itl okay do I have a second
second by represent
elberger and when you're done writing
I'll let you speak to your motion if
you'd like
to thank you thank you Mr chair thank
you Mr
chair um I was convinced during
open uh the full committee work session
that the fee involved goes to the town
clerks and City Clerks to offset some of
the cost and it's modest and so we
should it all
this representative Aly oh no sorry I
was just getting ready
oh anyone else on um like to talk about
HB
116 okay when the clerk is ready I'll
ask the clerk to take the role on HB
116 I have to take a second to write in
substitutes because I ran out of ones I
had
preone okay no
problem
all
set I'm
ready I'll it all right what is the
motion the motion is itl and I'm about
to read the rur call uh representative
janigian chairman janigian
this is itl and HP 1116 yes yes uh
representative is still not back uh
representative
erery yes representative
DEC he's out
okay representative spillsbury yes
representative plvs yes representative
lel's yes LEL sorry representative D
Simone yes representative or yes
representative roord yes
yes represent Aly
yes representative Ames yes represent
Southworth yes represent Malloy yes
representative shamberg yes
representative fellows yes
representative Bolton yes representative
elberger yes representative leapley yes
represent Smith yes vote is
180 two not
voting the vote being 180 um any
objections to consent seeing none we'll
put this on consent as
well um we are going
to skip over um
1054 and and um and then the last three
we are actually not bringing up I think
we agreed in work session yesterday that
HB 1193 1470 and
1613 um some further work was going to
be done on
those um so we have three bills left we
have uh
1054 cacr 15 and
1255 uh no I'm sorry 1525 which we are
waiting for an updated Amendment on
there was a one word error instead of an
employee it should say
employer
um we're gonna take a um yeah we're GNA
take a
um we'll take a break until um
11:45 yeah
on USS here yeah yeah um is there some
way that we can declare
a a non-executive session on his bill
which uh which bill was
that
1613 been sitting patiently oh yeah
we're not going to exec 1613 is that
what
but he has prepared an
amendment which I think
um maybe he would like to see if the
committee what the committee thinks
it did that go to
everybody do we have
Dem I don't think we have
it do we all have your it's not a
formal oh oh
okay I mean maybe the thing to do would
be to send us all an email with your
proposal is that it's represent Al me is
saying it's not in
a not an
amendment
yet yeah no well we're not actually on
it we're in we're in recess but we're
just giving you an opportunity
to sure it's an official one sounds like
it sounds like it I think he
had it's simple the hill
okay
my apology we ran out of things to do
that that that
turn
just so everyone knows um representative
Muse passed out a proposed amendment to
HB 1613 which we are not going to exec
today but uh for your reference you can
study it and um when we do have an exec
session on
1613 um we can consider that
we're still in recess I call a recess
till 11:45 so we need to stick to that
recess
11:45
okay the time being 11:50 we'll get
started back with our exec session here
um and we are going to start with uh
exing HB
1525 um representative ducet would you
like to make a
motion thank you Mr chairman I move
ought to pass on HB
1525 do I have a
second second by represent
ery would you like to speak to your
motion or offer an amendment yes I have
an amendment I'd like to offer we I just
placed in front of
you uh 2024 0711
H and do I have a second on that
Amendment second by representative
Southworth and as we discussed when I I
presented the uh the bill initially it
uh addresses
the drafting errors that were there
and thank goodness for uh representative
Ames catching yet another uh early this
morning um but IT addresses uh the
errors that were in the original
Bill okay could you please repeat that I
I I I know you I can't hear it
sorry could you repeat what you just
said sure when I presented the bill
initially there were a couple drafting
errors disc correct this amendment
corrects those drafting errors
representative a saw a another issue
this morning that's why we had to wait
for the Second Amendment to come down it
said employee where it should have said
employer in one of the two
spots any
discussion seeing none the clerk will
call the role on the amendment
okay amendment number 2024 0711 H and
the
uh and uh Ro going forward with that
chairman
jigan the motion being OTP o the
amendment the
amendment no I know but you didn't you
didn't mention the OTP on the
amendment yes okay
uh representative Edwards uh yes to
otpa am the amendment give me an a yeah
okay represent oler yes represent set
yes represent spillsbury yes represent
PL votes yes representative sodi uh
representative lels yes representative D
Simone yes repres ORS yes represent rord
yes represent Aly yes represent Ames yes
representative Southward yes
representative Malloy yes representative
shamberg yes representative fellow yes
represent Bolton yes representative
elberger yes representative
leapley yes representative Smith yes the
vote is 20 Z all all persons present the
vote being 20 to Z any objection to
consent no now that's the amendment otpa
now yes that was the second time I made
that mistake
okay okay uh is there a motion to
otpa there's a well there's
automatically a motion because we just
passed the amendment now the motion
asked had made a motion to OTP the bill
so now he has to make a motion to
OTP yes okay yeah would you like to make
OTP a
a on
1525 HB
71h
interesting any discussion on
otpa all right the clerk will call the
role okay uh this is otpa Chairman
janigian yes representative Edwards yes
representative erery yes represent jet
yes representative spillsbury yes
representative plots yes representative
L lels yes representative D Simone yes
represent ORS yes representative rord
yes represent Aly yes represent Ames yes
represent Southworth yes represent
Malloy yes represent shamberg yes
represent fellow yes represent Bolton
yes represent elberger yes
representative leapley yes
representative Smith
yes the vote is
20 okay the vote being 20 is there any
objection to
consent seeing none we'll go on
consent and I'll close the exact session
on hp1
1525 now open the exec session
on cacr 15 and
recognize representative olry for a
motion I move
OTP do I have a
second representative duet
seconds and would you like to speak to
your motion representative
erine very simple if we're going to take
money out of our neighbors Pockets it
ought to be something
that the majority of us more than just a
minor majority but a significant
majority agree that is necessary and
needed be that money a tax or a fee
understanding that in New Hampshire the
way we spell tax is
Fe thank thank
you do I have representative
fellows so my neighbors all own homes
and their taxes are going to go up
significantly their their property taxes
are going to go up significantly if we
pass this bill because it makes it just
about impossible to raise money from any
other
source anybody else representative
yeses um the comment made by
representative Fells factually
incorrect okay represent
elberger thank you Mr chairman
um I brought up before
that if we are asking for a 2third
majority to
raise taxes or fees then I believe we
should be also looking at 2third
majority to lower taxes or fees if we
are talking about being fiscally
responsible we
also uh as we mentioned yesterday talked
about the uh tens of million dollars of
increases in EFA account
costs that are not covered anywhere in
the budget the given the vast majority
of the students who are getting
those uh
efas are have never been in public
school there is no money that the public
schools will be transferring into those
account so those are new costs to the
state with no underlined No statement
about where that money is coming from
and we had the the house passed that
without
any uh statement or plan for covering
those the governor uh yesterday
announced that he wants to spend almost
a million dollars to send New Hampshire
National Guardsman to the southern
border there is no plan to cover that
expense we are going to be school
lawsuits that have been so far
successful
and I
don't
see that asking our local property
taxpayers to cover costs that are being
incurred by the state without any plan
on the state's part about how to
increase the funding and requiring then
a 2third majority to come up with a plan
makes any sense at all I see this as an
irresponsible fiscally irresponsible POS
uh recommendation and I will be voting
very strongly against it and speaking to
my constituents along those lines thank
you thank you anybody else
representative um May I respond um
okay let me uh we we'll get back to you
um representative Lee
Lee thank you Mr
chair um just want to reframe the idea
of taking I don't believe that tax ation
is theft or taking I believe that I was
handed many things when I was born and
when I as I move about in the state I am
given things like a road that gets me up
here to the state house this chair that
I sit on this table that I sit at I
think it was purchased by the last
generation of taxpayers and I feel like
it was a gift to me a gift to all of us
in the state
and what we are asked is to Simply pay
it
forward so that I I don't have to buy
this chair the last generation of
taxpayers bought it but it's fair that I
pay for upkeep for the Next Generation
so I feel like if we refuse to pay taxes
we're refusing in fact to pay back what
we already took and we're taking from
the Next Generation so I feel like we
can frame this however we want but there
is no such thing as a free lunch and I
think that there is a balance right now
if we want to make changes in taxation
or in spending we have to have a
majority to make that decision and I
think that that has served us well um so
far in New Hampshire history and I'm not
ready to make that change so I will be
voting no on OTP thank you thank you um
represent El did you want to say
something okay representative
Aly thank you uh this is totally
fiscally
irresponsible on you are looking at
having the General Court decide by 23s
whether to pay the pr interest in
installments of principal of all state
bonds that is going to destroy our
credit
rating and increase
the costs of government by a huge amount
um
2/3 is not a
democracy 2/3 is uh ruled by a
minority this
uh
legislation
to avoid any increases when increases
turn out to be necessary on is not
something that could pass with 2/3
unless it was something like a nuclear
bomb it hit the state uh we went through
this in
1999 when we spent eight hours on the
floor in in
uh the rep's hall trying to get through
something that would pay $800 million
for educ ation funding even though we
had all sorts of gimmicks in it a third
of it was the educ was the uh Statewide
education property tax so that uh we
weren't really paying it it was being
paid by local
taxpayers
um and um there were all sorts of other
things in it they came in they went out
we argued back and forth for eight hours
we were locked in until midnight
uh it must might have been more than
eight hours uh and we just and we
managed barely to pass it but we didn't
need
2/3 2/3 probably even back then when
Republicans were more
Progressive uh would have been just
about
impossible and um I think this is a
request to to destroy our state and I'm
definitely voting
against anything else any other
comments yes represent
elberger just to clarify because I saw a
couple of uh immediate reactions when
representative Aly was talking about
control by a minority what this means if
this is passed is that
onethird of the house
can control a
budget if there is not one3 Plus or 2/3
plus who vote to raise taxes or fees or
add new ones then in fact a minority of
the reps are in
control it's not a responsible way for
us to behave thank
you okay okay uh representative
Ames when we discussed this before I uh
made the point that uh this state has
functioned um reasonably well with its
ups and downs for uh centuries and um it
has done so with a simple majority rule
on most matters um apart from amending
the Constitution itself and um that uh
the matters that come before this body
are complex and difficult um and uh
sorting out uh the pros and cons is uh a
challenge for all of us um in the end
resolving those choices uh by a uh a
simple majority 50 50% plus one um is
the way we've done it uh we being the
the state of New Hampshire over the
years and um I see no reason whatsoever
to um move away from that uh that really
remarkable history of a functioning
democracy so um I I hope uh in the end
that we'll find our way to say no to
this uh I agree I'm sorry to label it
this way but I think it's absolutely
true with this uh fiscally
irresponsible uh
proposal
okay all right seeing no more oh one
more hand there representative
ery last comment if you will
sir um there's absolutely nothing in
this bill that prevents an increase in
taxes and nothing in this bill prevents
the payment of uh due
debts uh this bill using a super
majority reflects the operation of a
republic which is what we
are 2/3 is not a u minority and to say
that the one-third is
controlling an uh the the the body one
must remember that right
now five votes five people
control much rather have a
discussion
between a hundred people and their point
of
view rather than have a discussion with
five people who say absolutely no and
will
not discuss one way or another because
they are the ones that know what's
best this type of Bill
prevents the minority from
controlling and make sure that the
majority has a chance to present itself
position it all
when one talks about important
activities of the
legislature is most certainly true that
our constitution is the primary and
amending the Constitution has a a very
high
threshold the second most important
thing is how much money we impose to be
taken from our neighbors this does not
in increase property taxes property
taxes are assessed at a local
level local the the local communities
can and should not rely upon larest from
the state but should rely upon their own
activ uh efforts to pave the roads or
whatever the state when it has access
funds makes that available the state
through a variety of programs such as
meals and rooms which we discussed
earlier share
shes was some of the
burden I don't see how this could be
called fiscally irresponsible when it
mandates fiscal
responsibility enough set thank
you I can kind of guess what some of the
responses might be but um let's you know
try to stick to new areas
representative ORS thank you Mr chair I
just wanted to say that we are not a
democracy we are a republic thank you
very
much represent
elberger we impose taxes to provide for
the common good whether it's to pave our
roads plow our roads
protect our air protect the
water educate our
children we see those as our
responsibilities some of those things
are in fact embodied in the Constitution
state
constitution the notion
that there would be no impact on the tax
burden for our
citizens and specifically with regard to
to property
taxes doesn't make sense in my mind
every time we
cut taxes that the state levies that
support local
Services yes the state is not paying for
those services but I haven't heard
anybody saying we don't need to provide
services we don't need to plow our roads
we don't need to pave our roads we don't
need to do any of those those things
until and unless we are willing to say
we don't care about providing those
Services we can manage without them then
we need to pay taxes in order to do that
when we are not providing State funds to
our
municipalities those municipalities want
to maintain services and there is no
alternative to them other than to raise
property taxes those are connect
whether we like that idea or
not and we need to be honest and
recognize that that's the case thank
you representative Aly and then
representative
Edwards thank you um we all know this
bill is not going to pass because it is
not going to get 2third in the
legislature
um I uh I would like to just mention
that we are talking talking about small
D and small R de democracy in Republic
and we are both
um our constitution is framed that way
you may try to change it so that we
aren't any longer but um we are one in
which a majority vote me me means
majority vote it doesn't mean that on
you can't do
something because a third are against it
um I would just appeal to my
colleagues to think about what kind of
state we would be if we only had the
richest
communities in the
state and there were no other people in
this state thank
you represent
Edwards yeah thank you Mr chair I I I
hadn't expected to hear much discussion
in this bill related to uh the need for
government to provide services because
this is not an amendment dealing with
services this is an amendment dealing on
how we should handle new
taxes not existing taxes but new taxes
and so the debate to me would properly
be focused
on the right mechanisms in a in a
society to raise new taxes and and what
I've not heard from anyone is the
fundamental respect that we should have
for people who engage in the economy
create things produce wealth and do it
at Great sacrifice to themselves and to
their
families to so that they can take care
of themselves we we we should not expect
government to be sitting back looking at
the
production uh of that individual those
individuals as though their perception
of the common
good somehow gets confused with the
common possession of wealth and I you
know I I I think people should pay taxes
but I think we should do it respectfully
realizing that government at its core is
a force is is a CO of force and one of
the things we ought to be doing is
dampening the urge of individuals to use
that coercive
Force to do damage and and The Taking of
resources from an individual or a family
is damaging and I don't know that we
should pretend that it isn't because it
certainly is thank
you representative duet thank you Mr
chair and as as much as I don't want to
speak on this I'll be very very brief I
think if we've learned one thing in this
very evenly divided house session is
that a lot of things can happen
dependent on
attendance okay and the standard to
raise and imp Implement new taxes being
50% plus one to me doesn't make sense we
need to we need to find a common ground
in this okay it can't be that kind of
close and and I'd submit we're not going
to get a two-thirds majority on this
also but I think uh the argument should
be made that it there should be a
standard that that's attainable other
than 50% plus one thank you thank you
representative
lle thank you Mr
chair I'm basing these comments on what
this body has done recently I feel like
what we're talking about is not reality
like there's no threat in New Hampshire
that we're going to become California or
that we're going to become uh Marxist
communism what is reality reality that
we all
share uh is that we just cut a bunch of
taxes and that we're proposing to make
it
harder
to have any Revenue in the state our
committee is required to look at the
treasury and to consider the revenue so
that this committee would vote to make
it almost impossible to raise
revenue in the context of just having
cut a bunch of taxes where that is not
held to the same standard is is not
following things to its logical
conclusion so we can continue to spend
with 50 plus one we continue we can
continue to cut taxes with 50 plus one
both of which this body has
done recently and that we would make
this change within the context that we
are all living in is not logical so
we're saying we're going to H H hold
this to an super standard but we're
still going to spend and we're still
going to cut taxes in the same way we
always have it it is not going to lead
to a more balanced New Hampshire so I'm
G to vote OTP on this and I I hope thank
you I'm going to vote against the OTP
sorry I
misspoke um and I hope that we all can
think about the big picture nobody likes
paying taxes I think it's very
immature to have this attitude as
Governors we have to pay taxes if we
want to reap benefits that make this a
civilized Community where we live it it
just blows my mind that that we are
basically stamping our feet and saying
we refuse to pay our fair share which is
what this this bill is doing thank
you I'm going to take one last comment
from representative ORS and then I think
we are going to vote on this thank you
Mr chair and what I like to say is if I
take what
representative aim said and if I take
what representative ducet
said maybe a great way to balance this
out would be 2/3 to raise or lower taxes
it would give us time like we talked
about the other day to let things settle
another thought I had was if something's
passed like a tax or a cut it couldn't
be adjusted again till the next session
the next the next election but maybe a
great compromise would be to take this
2/3 you can't you can't raise taxes
without a 2/3 vote and you can't cut
taxes without a 2/3 vote and then we
could see what really what really
happens does trickle down really work or
does did raising taxes not hurt us thank
you I'll I'll take represent Ames you'll
be the last one I notic only because my
name was well I noticed your light was
on when I said he's the last one so give
you that that was happens now it's to be
truth truthful um yeah
uh no I don't I don't buy that my
comments lead to the suggestion that we
go with 2/3 and 2/3 and 2/3 um no way
I've spoken I've spoken in support of
the 50 plus one the majority rule
principle that uh has uh stood uh
through all these years and uh We've uh
done well with it thank you okay um I'm
going to ask the clerk to call the
role what is the motion please the
motion is ought to pass which I'm
calling the rle on and I'm calling first
on chairman
janigian yes representative Edwards yes
represent oler yes representative duet
yes representative spillsbury yes
representative plos yes representative
lels yes representative Deone yes
representative ORS yes representative
rosit yes representative Aly no
representative Ames no representative
Southworth no represent Malloy no
Representative shamber no representative
fellows no representative Bolton no
represent elberger no Representative
leapley no representative Smith no uh
vote being 1010 the mo
huh oh motion
101 motion is 1010 so the motion of
ought to pass
fails so it'll go it'll go with no
recommendation still shows up um so is
there a Minority Report oh well there
representative you're writing the um OTP
report on the no no
okay
May
yes you think there has to be a vote
well this um I guess this is the first
time we've run into this this but we'll
we'll just do it and then we'll we'll
confirm
later we don't need to vote on itl to
get to get a we're going to we're just
going to do take I'll vote for the
represent I thank you Mr chairman I
would I would offer you're going to end
up with the same effect it made a
difference in that last vote because
there was an amendment that somebody may
or may not voted different but it's
going to go with no recommendation and
yeah who don't need the it okay
wayes
Edwards let's just just just so we don't
make a mistake because we're not exactly
sure I I'd recommend we go ahead and
take an itl vote get the 1010 out of the
way and that way it's in the record
it'll still go forward as as a default
OTP yeah okay I'm all right with that
that's that's what I think let's uh
who's making the motion to itl all right
representative Aly itl second
from uh from representative
elberger okay all right the clerk will
take the role on in one second I shall
it's taking so
long okay
uh
Edwards we asked the Clark half the
question we didn't ask the other
should
yeah it's a good ide no I think it's
good all
right anyway the the vote the motion is
now it and I call on representative
janigian chairman janigian no
representative erery representative
Edwards no represent erery no
representative duet no Representative
spillsbury no representative PL votes no
representative LEL
no representa ORS no uh representative
Deone no uh Representative rord no
represent Aly yes represent Ames yes
represent Southworth yes represent
Malloy yes representative shamberg yes
representative fellows yes
representative Bolton yes representative
elberger yes representative leapley yes
representative Smith yes so the vote is
1010 uh for itl so so the motion
fails okay so representative er's going
to write the report for OTP
representative Al me the one for itl yes
how long do we have but not you should
have it done by now
um well if we're going to get them in
for for the next week then we need to do
them now
um I mean my preference would be to get
them in today before
3 um which I'll I mean I'll stick around
a little bit after we're done here to um
but we can discuss
individually yeah we we'll discuss
individually it's already done all right
um ol is setting the standard he's
already
done okay I'm going to um so the vote
was what 1010 101 either way all right
I'm going to close the exec session on
CAC
R15 all right
um we have one uh one bill left as I
said I'm not going to EXA the last three
today on the list here so lastly we will
exact HB 1054 and I'll open that exact
session now I'll recognize
representative uh roord for a which one
oh 10
1054 okay I move uh itl on HB
1054 do I have a second
second by representative ores would you
like to speak to your motion yes thank
you Mr chair
um I think it's important to really look
at what 1054 does and does not do so I
know that it's uh the issue of borders
and border crossings and Patrol
enforcement and whose job it is and
whose job it isn't can really cloud this
issue but the issue at hand with 1054 is
really do we lapse a fund or we do not
do we not lapse a fund this fund that
we're talking about um was just created
in the last budget so it's been only
active since
July we're finding that there are
unexpended funds in the budget
and the people making an argument for
lapsing this fund would point to those
unexpended funds currently but the
reality is we've only had access the
state has only been spending those funds
for six
months when you add on the fact that
Jael car only adopted the rules for this
program in
November it really isn't an accurate
picture on
on if if we're on track to expend These
funds furthermore my colleague from
holderness yesterday brought up a good
point she did the research she said
these funds are going to be used for
things like overtime
so if we're six months into a a two-year
fund there's no way that we can
anticipate whether or not overtime will
be expended now or
later so I think that I can speak for
many of my colleagues in the fact that
we don't want money sitting around and
we don't want money that's earmarked for
for a certain issue and not getting
spent to to go unspent but the reality
with 10
54 is that repealing this particular
dedicated fund is a premature action at
this time so with that I would uh again
reemphasize my motion for inexpedient to
legislate thank you um other comments
representative elme yes as I understand
the bill it is not repealing this fund
what it is doing is saying that the
excess that hasn't been spent at the end
of each bium is going to be lapsed to
the general
fund that's a quite a different thing
from repealing
it that is simply saying that the next
budget if they are needing continuing
money and have shown that they need the
money will have to have the amount
uh that is needed for that
bium in the
budget and that's the situation right
now except that they say that you can
build up a kitty over the years which
the Department of Safety in the past has
been really good
at thank you representative PL I accept
everything representative Aly said as
true ever I think the argument is it's
only been a few months and uh that we
should give this a couple of years
before we talk about uh uh putting
putting the money back into the general
fund we just have no track recet right
now represent roord yes I thank you Mr
chair I apologize if I if I
misrepresented uh um I understand what
the bill does and and and I'm not asking
and the bill does not repeal the fund
and I apologize to my colleagues here if
I uh I made that implied that but um
representative Aly is exactly right the
B the focus of the bill is do the funds
lapse or do they not lapse do they do
they build up or they do not do they not
build up and the point that I was making
is you know I don't think that we I
think we have a responsibility if they
are building up to return them to the
general fund but the point here is this
this fund has only been in existence for
six months the rules for the the the
program were and and how the funds get
expended have only been on the book
since November so again I I apologize if
I I Mis mispoke or misrepresented that
um because that was not the intent the
intent was exactly what my colleague
from Lebanon had said um but again
pointing out the fact that it's you know
too early to tell whether that's this is
needed or not Ren Bolton thank you Mr
chair so um I retire state after 30
years of working for both um d J and and
the Department of State and every two
years basically every agency goes back
and and renegotiates uh what they're
allocated and they basically put in um a
request for either more money or the
same money but um there are few uh
non-aps funds and if they are non-aps
funds then you know those get much more
scrutiny they have generally hopefully
um at least um a a group of people that
oversee see that that are uh unbiased
and regardless if this is an important
um entity that should survive their
funds will get reappropriated every bi
Anum and if they need more funds then
they'll go back to the legislature and
seek more funds and the legislature
would probably be sympathetic to that so
I think uh allowing it to lapse is
probably a very good thing for um this
fund and the department of safety so
thank you represent Edwards uh thank you
Mr chair so the state has no shortage of
funds that are non-aps It's Not Unusual
to have non-aps and funds generally I
want all the funds to lapse so that
Finance can take another look at it I
finance just debated this uh not too
many months ago really and determine
that in this case uh having the funds
non-aps makes sense because this is a
brand new
program um requiring the cross
coordination of multiple jurisdictions
Federal and local doing a number of
things to include uh uh refining their
communication equipment which can be a
longer leadtime procurement uh to
coordinate working out coordination
techniques and given that the money was
just allocated not all that long ago uh
would it would be expected for something
that complex to take a while to get done
and this money was allocated to get a
particular project done because it is
non-aps all that means is that this
project can be
completed we can determine in the next
budget cycle if additional projects or
additional money is needed but the
determination was made that this project
was vital to New Hampshire and this is
the amount of money to do it and the
non-aps respects the fact that it's new
and we could not anticipate the project
management schedule associated with it
so I I would recommend that that this
bill not uh that that the that this fund
remain
non-aps thank you representative fellows
um yes I'd like to point out that there
are restrictions on how the money in
this fund can be used it's restricted to
primarily overtime which could be for
local local police State Police fishing
game or Health and Human Services not
Health and Human Services Homeland
Security and uh it some money can be
spent for equipment there's still
another whole year to go by in the
existing appropriation that they have
for the bium which gives them plenty a
time to buy their equipment I I don't
think they need a huge amount of
equipment because you know these these
um officers that will be participating
already are employees of of either the
local or the state and they have their
uh equipment in
place um and that's the primary and they
they don't need they're not trying to
build um a new facility
that would certainly justify
non-lps and they're not um going to be
doing anything like a like a new
software system or any any major project
like that so there's just no reason that
it can't be lapsed and the department of
safety they will participate in the
regular bu budget process and they are
going to know what they want to ask for
in the different categories in terms of
overtime versus equipment and they're
the in the best position to do that uh
coordinating with their Partners the
advantage to collapsing money is that it
goes to Surplus and it can be used for
things across any of the needs that we
have in the state for example right now
what are people looking at in terms of
how they want we have Surplus and how
how would that Surplus be used and the
state is facing things like definitely
more money is needed for the settlement
cases at the um Youth Development Center
and there are many other projects and um
services that are have a really urgent
need for money so that's another reason
to uh lapse the money um because it
would becomes
available and it's excess money that
they didn't spend when you get to the
end of the bium that can be used for
other
services
represent Aly I have a question for
representative Edwards
on most of the money as I understand was
going to be spent on
overtime how is that not a recurring
expense that would not be a single
project the project is submitted was
defined by getting these multiple
jurisdictions working with each other
and uh and and securing the
border which is what a lot of the
overtime was for the idea was that by
being able to document the illegal
traffic coming across the border that
that would begin to create a data set
upon which a future legislature can make
make an informed decision
about the extent to which our border is
not secure and the extent to which we're
comfortable with that the the challenge
we had initially is that the federal
government maintains all of the data and
maintains of of illegal Crossings and
that data covers um something like 307
miles of which the the New Hampshire
portion is is but 54 of them and they
don't keep track of the data by border
segment they just keep track of by the
whole length and so uh the finance
committee as we looked at this with the
AG's request uh we we did not have the
the data that would really be useful in
future decisions but we believed in the
trends we believed in the scenario and
so we said okay here's a here's a
one-time bullus of $1.4
million get this coordination get the
communication get the surveillance up so
that when you come back we have some
data upon which to decide what we should
do in the future does that answer your
question
um Yes except that we've got the data
now the ACLU extracted it from the
federal government
on the I'm sorry I'm not going to
believe them I I I think we need to
collect our own data I'm I'm
sorry well they had a certification from
the attorney whatever you call the
attorney that represents the federal
government in New Hampshire uh that this
was the data that had been sent by
HMS I mean it just
my thought would be that the when the
finance committee took this up they
looked into
the as as representative Edwards has has
mentioned there's a lot of coordination
that goes on it's a new fund do make
sense that we would give it more time to
to settle in um because uh represent
Edwards you you made the statement that
there are a lot of non-aps yes funds and
that it's This Is Not Unusual and
especially where it's it's a new fund
why are we why are we rushing to to do
something why don't we let it settle in
and see what happens uh representative
uh uh
leapley followed by representative
elberger thank you Mr chair um am I
correct that the motion on the floor
is itl yes thank you so the motion on
the floor being
itl we're proposing that we
not look at this fund at the end of this
bium that we not
question whether we've appropriated the
right amount of money that we not
question how much more we should
appropriate in the next bium so what
we're proposing is that we let I don't
let me just stop you for a second no
that's not true all we're saying is it
should
be a well the bill want to be a lapsing
fund which means the money goes back so
um we're not saying anything about you
know whether we're not going to look at
it or or things like that it's just this
is lapsing versus non-aps and Edward so
let me restate and see if I have it
right so if we itl this bill we're
saying that the the funds should
stay in the account so if this project
if they spend the money if they don't
spend the money the money will sit in
their account and then in two years it
will sit in the account two years from
then it'll sit in the account so we're
not
automatically allowing the funds to go
back into the general fund we are um
assuming that the fund is
operating as it should be and that the
appropriation next time should stay at
the same amount I don't I would say no I
I'll well I'll let represent Edwards
answer that but I thank you this is a
one-time allocation of funds for
one-time project and the expectation is
that the attorney general who started
this project uh in the summer is
continuing to assertively execute the
project and is spending that money down
the amount of money that we might be
talking about at the end of the budget
would be minimal really and all we would
be saying is that for the the purposes
of this one project that we authorized
that they could finish spending it in a
normal amount of time now if something
bizarre happens and they just quit
spending it which I don't anticipate
that's very odd they uh then there are
ways for that money to be recouped in a
future budget cycle but the idea that
we're going to be
leaving money lying about for a while is
just I I I I just don't see that
as
um being a a a a likely
scenario so we I I can see
opposing I just the purpose of the
project but from a money perspective
this is not a a money issue at this
point it's let's just do the project
let's get the data let's find out in
future
sessions what the extent is to which our
borders being
violated get the
information did you have a followup um I
just wanted to clarify so the the money
is a one-time one time it's not a fund
that is going to exist in the next banum
so it's $1.4 million one time and it's
not being reappropriated next time
around okay so I'm going to talk about
practical and Technical okay and there's
going to be a distinction practically
what you said is right this is onetime
money and it's just going to get spent
down
okay
technically some bureaucrat somewhere
has to turn off the fund and that
requires a level of of administrative
detail that the legislature won't get
into but from a practical perspective
this is a one-time project and it and
this money is going to get spun down
this is not an open fund for us to to
continually appropriate and if we do
appropriate it's going to be because the
finance committee and other committees
uh have received data suggesting that
this is useful so uh I I wouldn't assume
anything about the future unless you're
willing to assume what the future data
is going to suggest I I think we will
retain our judgment and
discretion
it's uh yes representative elme on does
this have a 612
number technical detail I don't know be
well it's not a technical detail because
if it is in 612 the legislature has to
actually to get rid of
it even and until we get rid of it if
there's no further use for it uh then um
it will on remain on the
books um I mean even if that's true it's
not like no one's ever going to look at
it I mean we're constantly looking at
funds the finance committee no no the
finance committee on representative
Edward was was right they've got a lot
of stuff that they have to do the reason
that the dedicated fund committee exists
still and is active is that on at least
every five years we look
at all of the uh of the funds that are
on still on the books and we get rid of
the ones that are doing nothing and we
do something about the funds that don't
have enough money in them to do what
they were supposed to be doing or have
decided like that agricultural one did
that they're going to use it for
something totally different but the
point is it's going to get reviewed it's
not it gets reviewed once every five
years okay representative uh Elber yeah
very briefly the essence of
Representative rushford's argument was
that it's a premature action none of the
prerogatives of the next legislature are
in any way curtailed the next
legislature can look at the question of
lapsing it can look at the um question
of eliminating it when
inactive or can look at the question of
whether further funds and a new
appropriation are necessary this is a
premature
action represent
elberger thank you Mr chairman I guess
that um I must have been ignorant about
the fact that this is as representative
Edwards points out a one-time project if
this is a one-time project presumably it
has an end
date if it's a one-time project you're
shaking your head no so if it's a
one-time
project how will we know when it's
done and what does done mean in the
context of this project the AG will
inform
us I I
don't inform us of
what you you asked the question and one
will we know it'll it done and the AG
will inform us this is a high priority
special project that people are keeping
an eye on this is not something that's
being done in the you know mushrooms in
the basement this is this the AG is
executing this assertively and is
maintaining managerial
control if if you want to know the
status you could call the AG and he'll
just tell you this is not a secret that
if I'm working on on a
project my project has a point it has an
outcome and the outcome at least
theoretically should be measurable I
don't
know how we know when this project is
done because we don't know I don't know
what the purpose is I was under the
impression that this
program was to keep track and
interdict uh people illegally coming
into New Hampshire across the
border that to me is not a one-time
project it's an ongoing purpose I assume
now that I have this all wrong no
so how is that if if I'm accurate I
don't understand how this is a one-time
project rather than an ongoing
activity represent Edward thank you Mr
chair the other thing that I said in
this meeting is that it's also to fund
Communications equipment because as you
get up along the northern border there
the ability to communicate across
International lines and even within New
Hampshire's Northern borders is
extremely limited so so so some amount
of the money that's for this project is
explicitly for communications equipment
and in order to figure out what kind of
Communications equipment they needed
they would have to work out what sort of
international laws or I this is more
than I had said before but they have to
work out the international complexities
of communication law at the border it's
a major problem that law enforcement
cannot talk to each other up there they
cannot do that now so if we get this
communication equipment in place these
jurisdictions can coordinate their
activities better and create a better uh
net to catch illegal
Crossings so so we didn't know how long
it would take it it it it's being
executed and if you'd like I'll call the
AG this afternoon and find out the
status but the question is should this
fund lapse or not and I I I'd say it
should not lapse it should let the
project execute and and it's it's not
like we're going to waste time on
it um
I'm I'm hearing contradictions it's an
ongoing project but it has but it's a
one-time project we need the Fone funds
to be
ongoing if we need the funds to be
ongoing we need to have accountability
on those
funds
the
uh expenditure was okayed through 2025
correct when we passed the budget it was
through 2025 Mr
chairman represent yes okay so we
have almost two
years to take a look at what the data
are
and I don't see any reason
to let the funds remain in this account
without finding more information about
what they've been used for how they
might might be needed in the future and
we as a legislature can allocate new
funding every bium if we believe that it
needs to be allocated thank
you represent
fellows so in listening to this
conversation I think that some people
when they hear onetime project they
think of something with a an end date
you know something that's going to take
two years and then be done and I think
that that's probably for the general
public not the best way to characterize
it I think what this is is you it might
be a pilot project or a startup project
and that certainly Justified putting uh
$1.4 million into their budget but going
forward there's no difference there's no
impact on what money they will have
available to them to spend if this money
lapses the money that they haven't spent
and haven't obligated obligated lapses
at the end of the year and doing that
makes it available for other needs that
the state will have and this is all
something that's going to happen a year
from now in the department of safety I
don't I'm not sure um why why um
representative Edwards um mentioned the
AG the budget is actually in the
department of safety they would be
putting together with input from
whomever is necessary their budget and
that the issue is it's not they're going
to get whatever money they ask for and
that the legislature decides that they
need and so whether you lapse it or not
the only thing that does is makes laps
money is available to address other
needs when it's Surplus it's Surplus
they couldn't spend it they couldn't off
obligate it they had some money left at
the end of the bium that's going to end
in July you know June 30th
20125 and then by that time we will have
voted a new budget for that project
thank you repres ORS so I just did a
search and it says here that more than
12,200 migrants were apprehended
Crossing illegally from Canada in 2023
and up Tock a 200
141% with
3,578 arrests and then the next one goes
on into the New York I'm yeah New York
Vermont New Hampshire border which I
forget what they called that again the
Swanson and then it goes on to say that
uh although the numbers for New
Hampshire's border crossing may not be
exact and it goes on to qu quote
governor sonunu and you know on and on
and on so all I'm saying is you know we
heard from uh the ACLU that officially
two people across the border when you do
a search you know we're getting numbers
like who knows uh 12 up to 12,000
crossing the border and uh so I think
it's obvious this fund is needed for a
while probably I mean we can we can uh
sit here and kick this can back and
forth but I think it's time to
vote
represent
leapley thank you Mr chair I just want
to clarify if if people are watching um
at home the what we're voting on is
actually the change of two words it's
not just lapsing or
non-aps it says the the law now it says
the fund shall be non-aps and
continually
appropriated and what we're taking out
are the words non-lps and
continually so it is about continually
enlaps and I I think the feeling is I'm
not opposed
to the project it's happening I'm
opposed to the idea that we would
continually appropriate money for
something that is being presented as a
one-time thing
and if we want to be running an
efficient lean mean State we should be
reviewing this kind of spending
regularly with each bium especially
something that's new so this is new
spending we should keep an eye on it
great I'm glad we're we're collecting
data I want to be a datadriven decision
maker but but then that means we have to
review the
data thank
you uh representative PL just say
there's no such thing as continually
because one legislature can't bind
another and and so and so next bium when
we go through a budget the finance
committee can do what it needs to do
regardless of what that language is and
I I say we've discussed this I'd like to
call a question if that's possible very
quick clarification yeah continue ually
appropriating means that the
appropriation continues beyond the bium
of this 1.4 million it doesn't say you
keep one putting another 1.4 million
in okay good
distinction all right um did you have a
question uh represent Malloy earlier
that I didn't see okay all right um I
think we are ready to vote so I'll ask
the clerk to take the
role the motion is itl I call on
chairman
janigian yes representative Edwards yes
represent Hy yes represent duet yes
represent spillsbury yes representative
plots yes representative LEL yes
representative DeSimone yes
representative ORS yes representative
rord yes representative
Aly representative Ames no
representative Southworth no
representative Malloy no represent
shanberg no represent fellows no
represent Bolton no represent elberger
no represent leapley no represent Smith
no okay vote is 1010 the motion itl
fails okay well I guess we learned from
the last time around that
now we have to go OTP is someone making
an OTP
motion
representative
okay fellows fellows ought to pass
elberger
second would you like to speak to your
motion
briefly thank
you
okay I'll ask the clerk to take the role
on
OTP
okay motion being ought to pass on 10 Mo
on Bill 10 1054 I call in chairman Janan
no representative valry excuse me
represent Edwards no Representative
erery no representative duet no
Representative spillsbury no
representative plots no Representative
lels no representative D Simone no
representative ORS
no okay that stretched it out
Representative rosit no representative
Aly representative Ames yes represent
Southworth yes represent Malloy yes
represent shamberg yes represent fellows
yes representative Bolton yes
representative elberger yes
representative leapley yes
representative Smith yes the vote is
1010 the motion not to pass
fails okay um so it'll go to the floor
with no
recommendation representative roord
you'll write the itl motion and
represent fellows the OTP there where no
no recommendation on this form come on
well um so let me close the exec section
on HB 105
4 that concludes um our business our
exec session today because as I said
previously we will not EXA the last
three we're getting some additional
information and we'll have most likely
work sessions on those representative
Aly did you have a question well we do
have the additional information I
think microphone sorry I think we've got
the additional
information from representative m moods
but
maybe on at least if um you could tell
him whether we're going to be executing
these next
week we have everything we need I'm not
sure he can hear us but okay he left his
hearing aids at home I mean if we have
everything we need for executing
um I don't see why we couldn't do
it so we have um so I take that back
we'll take a look at uh 1613
and um yes did you have a question I I
just wanted to apologize to uh
representative Aly for uh my Outburst
when she mentioned um uh the you that
organization with four letters uh that
was uh inappropriate and um I I I do
apologize I hope you'll accept that
apology thank you yes thank you um
so we'll take a we'll take we'll take a
look at uh 1613 and decide whether we go
to a vote or not um so I'll open the
exec session on HB
1613 and
um could you
recognize actually
um or get everybody to read the
amendment
okay yes um we'll make a somebody needs
to make a motion on it first um actually
I'm
gonna I'm going to take a two-minute
recess on this for a second I haven't
had a chance to read this amendment I
don't even know what we're talking about
can we please put this off to next week
uh that's what I was that's what I just
taking recess I think we need to put it
off um so we have your Amendment thank
you representative Muse um um and uh
we'll consider it we'll put this on the
list for next
week thank you Mr chair the
um what the amendment does just so you
know is uh the uh Department of
Environmental Services uh raised some um
significant uh uh questions and
objections I think during the public
hearing what what this does is
effectively address their exemptions it
it turn turns the fund that would be
created into a non-aps fund uh which was
one of the biggest things it also
provides more flexibility to the
commissioner of Environmental Services
to uh to be able uh to essentially uh
spend any funds that are left over after
the initial uh uh contamination that the
settlement was received for has been
remediated so if there are leftover
funds uh it provides a lot more
flexibility the than the original Bill
around what those funds can be spent on
so it still requires that um that the
money be spent on remediating or
addressing environmental contamination
in some way but what it does is it is it
puts that within the statutes that apply
to the Department of Environmental
Services as opposed to Health and Human
Services as we had originally and
essentially just cleans it up uh so so
it's in a position for you to to
consider whether or not it's something
we want to adopt as a policy okay great
thank you thank you for coming today and
and distributing that all right um I'm
going to
uh yeah so um I'm going to run through
very quickly the list of who's who's
doing uh
reports I'll just go in order that we
did them today
1254 is
um representative spill
B
uh and Al and represent
Aly and I had volunte
thises to write
I of the
P okay HB 123 is representative
PL um 1255 is representative
leapley 1389 is representative Shamburg
1525 is representative duet as well as
1549 cacr 15 is Ol o2p and alme
itl 116 is representing
PL and 1054 is representative roachford
and who's doing the
OTP was it fellows
okay okay I'd like
um it would be ideal to get as many in
today as possible but I realize um it is
um
so so so if are these if you get the
reports are they going to when are we
going to hear those on the house floor
it wouldn't
be would it be next week Friday it's
Thursday you know speaker would decide
but it could be um it could be as early
as next Thursday okay but it wouldn't be
the one after that because that's a
vacation week the one after that the
speaker said there'll be no house
sessions so if we don't if the report is
not in today by 3:00 then these aren't
going to be heard until
March for the good of the committee can
I give an update from
General
sure representative Edwards is going to
give us an update from attorney general
fora so I text did the Attorney General
uh with some basic questions and he was
able to respond in text and I'll just
read it um uh to the question of uh are
they overseeing the project given that
the money is in the public safety budget
he says yes we are over seeing going
well so far we be began patrols with
State Police beginning of December had
hoped to start a couple weeks earlier
but we spent more time training than we
thought because we trained over a 100
Troop trouers GNC just approved 519,000
for locals a couple of weeks ago so they
will join soon after training the money
is in the department of safety's budget
I don't have a great estimate off the
top of my head on when funds will be
fully committed but I can get back to
you on that so so uh I'll go ahead and
ask him to try to come up with an
estimate because I think it's just good
general information and something that
maybe would be useful uh in the house
session just what the GNC approved
what
$519,000 to go to training uh
locals that was part of the $1.4
million I I I it could it can just be a
trans intergovernmental transfer too I
don't I don't know the mechanics I don't
know that it matters it's 59 of the 1.4
million all right so um yeah given the
deadline is 3:00 for me to get in
um uh the uh reports committee reports
it's a tight time frame if anyone is
able to get them done by then it's
appreciated because we can get them Mr
Cher I sent your mind for
1255 okay email yes your email thank
you so if if you're able to get them
done now or before three I'd appreciate
it but yeah uh cacr 15 I would prefer to
be able to to um confer with the other
Democrats before I send it
in can okay okay Mr chairman yeah can I
suggest that on the three bills where we
divide it evenly that a little bit more
time and consideration be given to the
reports and that we not try and Rush
those onto the calendar for the
22nd U it seems that's uh how others
feel I think that makes sense um the
ones that were um you know 19 to Z 20 to
Zer if those reports can be uh done but
but if not you know see me I guess see
me if you don't think you can get your
report done before 3 o'
today so you're in including also the
now for next week I I need to
uh figured that out there are four new
bills in the committee I'm probably
going to have a public hearing on each
of those four um and then
um and then possibly a uh work session
following those four but right right now
I'm uh you'll you'll know um or I can
send out an email um later today or
tomorrow as to what the schedule is
going to be but right now Tuesday and
Wednesday are still possibilities next
week the following week there'll be no
there'll be
nothing all right I think that does it
for today excuse me Mr chairman yeah
will you be executing bills next
week
possibly in the case that you need
substitutes I just want to be sure to
check my calendar I'd be happy to
substitute but I want to be sure that
I'm available okay that's all thank you
yeah thank
you all right no one has any other
questions I think we're all set for
today thank
you